Good morning John,
and good morning YouTube.
I,
from the waist up at least...
am dressed quite nicely!
and that is because I am here
to introduce what I believe
to be THE largest YouTube
Community-inspired event..
EVER.
It's called
The Project for Awesome.
Very basically,
The Project for Awesome is
a day in which the YouTube
Community takes over YouTube
in order to discuss and promote
the work of people who are
doing things because they
believe it is the right
thing to do, not because
they believe that it is
the way that they are gonna
make the most amount of money in the world.
In English, we generally
call that 'charity',
and so we do our part.
One day out of the year,
during this lovely holiday
season, to promote charity
here on YouTube.
And then the day after, we'll
go back to singing silly songs,
filming your cat
doing cute things, and
being generally profane, and alienating people's parents,
and so on.
This year's Project for Awesome
I am officially announcing
will be taking place
December 17th, 2008.
All of this will be organized
onto the Project for Awesome
website which is at
ProjectForAwesome.com
So there are 2 ways
to participate in
The Project For Awesome.
Hopefully you will do both,
but maybe you will
just do one of the two!
First is to make a
Project for Awesome video.
The steps for that include...
Step 1: Make a video about
your favourite charity!
I could make a video about
Toys for Tots!
Or the Nature Conservancy
or Save Darfur!
It doesn't matter.
Make a video as normal,
put a little bit in there
about your favourite charity
and why you think it's a great thing to give to this charity,
why you yourself give
to this charity,
why you hope more people
will give to this charity.
TWO:
Make the following image, or
a variant of it, your thumbnail
for that video.
We'll talk a little bit
more about that soon.
Three: Make sure your tags
and your video name include
the words 'Project for Awesome'
and your charity.
Four: Link to your charity's
Youtube channel in the sidebar.
If they don't have one,
then a link to their website.
And Five: Submit your video
to the Project For Awesome
using the 'Submit Your Video'
link at the top of the
ProjectForAwesome.com
webpage.
The second way to
participate is to be a
Project for Awesome Supporter!
(imitating a member):
'I'm a proud member of the
Project for Awesome
Supporters.'
And basically all you have to
do to be a Project for Awesome
Supporter is to sign up for
the Project for Awesome
mailing list which is
on the sidebar of
ProjectForAwesome.com.
The Project for Awesome
mailing list at the website
will only be used for
The Project for Awesome.
You will never get an email
after December 20th, I promise!
We will never give your
email address to anyone else!
We will NOT use it as
underarm deodorant!
We will NOT sell it to
the highest bidder!
Throughout the days of
The Project for Awesome,
The Project for Awesome
mailing list will feature
certain videos. Those videos
will be rated, and commented
and favourited like CRAZY,
so that those videos will
hit the big lists,
like the Most Discussed list.
And that way more people
will see those videos!
And then by the end of
The Project for Awesome
all of the videos on all of
the big lists,
and a bunch of the videos
that are currently being
watched on YouTube, and the
Most Viewed videos on YouTube
will ALL be part of
the same project.
And you will be able to tell,
because they will all have
similiar titles and
similar thumbnails!
And they'll be
EVERYWHERE!
And everyone will know
that YouTube is AWESOME!!
We have editable Photoshop
and Fireworks files
at ProjectForAwesome.com
So you can change things around
and make things unique
to yourself, as long as you
can tell that it's still a
Project for Awesome video.
So basically like,
you could do this...
Or you could do this...
But don't do THIS...
But you could do THIS.
And you could do this,
or this...
but not this.
NOT this.
Now before I get into
some of the details about
how to make your screenshots
work, I would like to make
a very special announcement.
My brother and I,
who run this channel together
(vlogbrothers),
have both decided to put up
a thousand dollars
that we will be donating to a
Project for Awesome charity
because of
The Project for Awesome
because it's not just about
talking about charities,
it's about GIVING to charities.
We will decide this based
not only on the
quality of the charity, but on
the quality of the video
made ABOUT the charity.
So make good videos
about charities!
And maybe YOUR charity will
get a thousand dollars
from John and Me!
Woo!!!
And if anybody else
wants to do a similar thing
where they award money, we
really encourage you
to do that!
I'm so excited about seeing
those screenshots spread
throughout all of the world!
Okay for people who are making
Project for Awesome videos,
we have to talk a little bit
about your thumbnails
because there have been some
changes to the way that
YouTube has decided
whats a thumbnail,
and what's not the thumbnail.
So we've talked wth YouTube
a little bit,
and there are 2 solutions
to this problem.
One only works if you
are a partner.
If you are NOT a partner,
what you need to do is
make sure that the middle ten
seconds of your video is
JUST the image.
I HAVE done a lot of research
uploading sample videos
making sure that this works,
and it DOES work.
If it's ten seconds long and
it's in the middle of the video
then YouTube will make it
the thumbnail for your video.
So if it's a 3 minute video,
it's like the ten seconds
from 1:25 to 1:35.
And that's all you need to do
to get your thumbnail to be
Project for Awesome.
... worthy.
Okay I gotta go - bye!
Closed Captioning
provided by CaptionThis
CaptionMyVideo@live.com